[موسيقى]
تعني كلمة "هونغ كونغ" باللغة الصينية "المرفأ المعطر"
في الواقع أن الميناء عبارة عن
قناة تقطع بحر الصين الجنوبي قد
نقلت البضائع الحيوية التي كانت جزءًا
من تقاليد التجارة في هونغ كونغ والتي
تشمل أيضًا
صانعي الملابس المتجولين في العالم
الذين يتعاملون مع  الإقامة المؤقتة في
المدن النائية تقيس العملاء وهم
يصنعون البدلات المخبأة هنا بعيدًا
في ممر التسوق في كولون
، لا يدع خياط Sam الخاص به هذا الخداع الخارجي المتواضع ،
مرحبًا بالحائط معرض للخياطة الخادعة
لأولئك الذين ارتدوا ملابسهم  بقلم
سام ، هذا أب وابنه
مانو و Rochon Malwani يدير المكان
الذي تعرف أنه أحد الأماكن القليلة
التي أشعر أنني في ملعب افتتح Sam
Milani
المتجر في عام 1957 وهو من بين
الرواد الذين أتوا إلى Hong  لقد وجد كونغ
نجاحًا إلى الأبد في تغيير عادات الخياطة
، لقد كان خياط سام يقطع بدلاتي
لمدة عقد من الزمان مقلمة ، أريد عرضًا متوسطًا قياسيًا ،
ولم يكن هناك عصر نمو
كان متأخرًا  أبي الذي علمني كيف
أقدر قطعة قماش جيدة هذه الأيام ،
لا أستمتع أكثر من اختيار
النمط الصحيح ، النسج الصحيح
وبالطبع البطانات ، إنه شيء أستمتع به
من تربيتي ، يتباهى خياطو هونغ كونغ
بأنهم يستطيعون صنع بدلة في يوم
أفضل  لقد استغرقت وقتًا أطول قليلاً ، ولا يمكنك
التسرع في ارتداء بدلة جيدة ،
شكرًا لك سيدي